before I really dive into this talk I'd
like to do a brief overview of electron
itself so at the highest level it's a
JavaScript framework that first sprang
into existence about five years ago its
impact lies primarily in its ability to
for the first time allow developers to
write applications for desktop platforms
using web technologies like JavaScript
CSS and HTML instead of system languages
like Objective C and C++ electron embeds
chromium and node.js which comprise
front and back-end components were
originally developed for web
applications so what can it do exactly
the embedded components I just mentioned
node and chromium allow electron to do a
pretty wide range of things for example
electron has access to all of nodes
native modules so you can interact with
the file system through the FS module
you can also create menus windows and
communicate between processes with these
capabilities you can bring features and
processes that were previously confined
only to the web to desktop applications
so briefly electron in the wild here you
can see a small handful some of the more
well-known electron apps which I've
chosen to showcase some of the abilities
that it brings you electron and nabel's
cross-platform web development
I mean desktop development by lowering
the barrier to entry which means that a
smaller team can access multiple
development platforms more cheaply than
if they had to build and maintain
multiple separate desktop apps electron
also allows developers to build things
that weren't previously possible one
example of this would be the
peer-to-peer space because of chromium
developers have access to web
our TC so that streaming peer-to-peer
content over the internet it's simpler
than it's ever been
now let's dive into the electron
ecosystem and talk about where we've
been where we find ourselves now and
where we think we're going we'll do this
by looking at four ways that electrons
changed in the past year roadmapping
upgrades community and processes will
start with community when I join the
team about 10 years ago or ten years ago
Wow a year ago that's awkward we had a
pretty healthy developer community but
the core team was small and so time
constraints meant that we needed to
spend most of our time looking
internally as a result we weren't able
to spend and engage with the larger
community working on electron as much as
we wanted to as the ecosystem and usage
of electron have grown our core team has
grown as well this has given us more
bandwidth to address developers needs
and work more closely with external
contributors we're actively trying to
recognize everyone who adds value to
electron whether they contribute by
pushing code or through other channels
one key example of this would be the
work that's been done in the past year
around internationalization of our
documentation and website this effort
makes electron more accessible to
developers around the world and
absolutely would not have been possible
without the work of contributors taking
time to translate our documentation and
work with us to crowdsource changes
they're all stages of the process right
now community decisions are made through
a democratic consensus process
which is worked well and has allowed us
to move forward effectively soon however
we may move to formalize and alter this
process in order to set electron up for
the highest chance of long-term success
hope I'm a little bit deeper into our
plans for governance later on in this
talk involvement in the community range
is pretty significantly in terms of
degree and type that an individual can
possibly have I mentioned our
translators earlier who helped show that
what constitutes involvement in an
open-source project can't really be
unilaterally defined instead we found
that the success of the electron
community is a function of the fact that
our members don't have all the same
needs interests and skillsets finally
how can you get involved in electron
this is something that we've worked to
clarify over the past year by adding
documentation around how our team
approaches development and how you can
find your niche within that we've also
been focusing on labeling issues as good
first issues when we think we'll help a
contributor from layer eyes themselves
with the code base and thus break into
open source development we've also had
core team members pair with some members
of the community which helps them get
features and fixes merged into electron
core so they can get just a taste of
what it's like to work in a workflow
similar to ours these efforts have also
prompted the team to improve our own
workflows because sometimes we've found
that it's hard to see what's unclear or
confusing about something that you've
been looking at day in and day out for a
pretty long time and I'd like to move a
little bit into how we work as a team
initially electron was a github project
but now our team is made up of folks
from a variety of companies
including slack Microsoft and Atlassian
who employ folks to work directly on
electron we're spread out across time
zones and also across countries raging
as you can see there from Japan to India
all the way in the United States which
means we've had to leave behind older
synchronous ways of doing things because
it's kind of hard to expect people to be
sort of awake and already to work at
times you're awake if they're just going
to bed or getting up or whatever really
as an any distributed open-source
project meetings are hard but we work to
accommodate everyone's needs as we
maintain what is functionally a 24 hour
development cycle we also work as a
cross company team as I mentioned a
little bit earlier even though we're
employed by different companies we meet
with each other directly and attend all
the same stand-ups surrounding electron
related content
now upgrades we've under a few
dependencies an electron but the two
that require continual upgrading and
maintenance are node and chromium we
maintain a fork of node in our
organization as well as a fork of
chromium we call Lib chromium content
this name is such because it's a shared
library build of the content module in
chromium we selectively pull in a few
other aspects of chromium but really we
only bundle the content module in the
past year we've seen some pretty
significant changes around how we
maintain both of these dependencies I'll
start with node regarding node
maintenance we're now working farm work
closely with the node core and its
surrounding community which allows us to
anticipate changes between node versions
and anticipate how they'll affect our
own code we also maintain 20 or so
patches we apply to each successive node
upgrade
in our personal fork while the patches
work now we'd ideally like to have to
patch less so that our maintenance
burden is correspondingly decreased to
that end we're also now working with no
developers to upstream patches in a way
that benefits everyone
one last key thing here that we've
learned through trial and fun error is
that just because a patch applies
cleanly doesn't mean you can necessarily
assume that it's going to have the same
effect that it has historically in one
fun recent example I went digging around
some source code of a patch that we'd
applied to figure out how to best
upstream it and in the process found out
that the thing it was originally
designed to do hadn't actually happened
in about three years it turns out it was
fixed upstream in a way that let the
patch continue to apply cleanly but that
rendered our patch useless so we figured
out we could just remove it and nothing
would actually happen
so now chromium when I first started we
were consistently about 8 or 9 versions
behind chromium's current stable version
our goal has been to catch up to that
stable and beyond and well we haven't
necessarily had that goal yet we've
gotten progressively closer as time has
passed right now
chromium which releases every six weeks
is in version 67 electron in current
beta 3.0 is using chromium 66 so what
changed what allowed us to go from 8 or
9 versions to just a single version
behind for one we got more efficient at
upgrading and have more resources and
engineers who devote their time to the
process it's also important here to
discuss why exactly we care about
keeping and killer bug catching up to
chromium and then once we get there
staying there if electron contracts
stable more closely then our team can
better communicate with the chromium
team to prepare for breaking changes to
the functionalities that electron relies
on in that way upgrading chromium to
stay in stride with all our upgrading
to stay in stride with chromium
functions is a positive feedback loop
the closer we get the easier it is to
stay there ideally we want to end up
tracking chromium's canary such that we
can see how their changes affect us
almost immediately and not some months
down the line now I'll move to processes
by processes here I mean non-technical
processes or guides that we've created
to systematically address different
problems as they arise recent changes
focus on defining and implementing
processes to be clear and extensible
which in turn helps the core team move
forward quickly and efficiently the
first three of the main areas we've
improved processes is our approach to
end-of-life previously we had several
release branches that they'll be cut
from but it wasn't necessarily very
clear to a user to what degree of
maintenance each branch was under and
what they could expect moving forward in
terms of support for a given branch we
spent some time discussing the
trade-offs of each particular form of
end-of-life and ended up settling on a
process whereby the latest three release
branches would be supported by the
electron team to put it in more concrete
terms
our latest stable release line is 2.0
point X and so we currently support that
line in addition to the 1.8 point X line
and the 1.7 point X line when 3.0 enters
stable developers will be able to know
then that we no longer actively support
1.7 point X and that they should update
accordingly now issue triage in tracking
this is kind of an ongoing deal in open
source where we still use our issue
tracker to see what the primary issues
are that users experience for each
version and what new features they'd
like to see in subsequent versions we
found though that since we have such a
wide range of use cases it was pretty
difficult for us to figure out what bugs
prevented app 2
developers from upgrading to more recent
versions and to answer the pretty
difficult question of when a version or
beta becomes stable in response to this
question we started what we're calling
the App Developer Program or the app
feedback program developers who track
metrics on their electron apps can
participate by deploying with our betas
and letting us know how many user hours
of beta testing is being done and then
also which issues they're seeing this
measurement strategy has several angles
it not only lets us know what bugs are
cropping up but also the frequency to
which they're being seen and the impact
that they're having on end-users with
that information we can better
prioritize our next steps and better
answer the question of what determines
stability in a way that's more empirical
unless anecdotal now back boarding our
back porting process highlights the line
that divides what can be automated and
what can't
during a hack week a few months ago a
few of us drank it was probably far far
too much coffee and use github apps and
Probot to create a bot that responds to
events on github if functions by opening
up back port pro requests to specified
release line branches when pull requests
are merged to master we tagged pull
requests with labels to let the bot know
where to back port them but whitelisted
developers can also post a comment to a
given PR that will manually trigger the
process recently get I've actually
exposed an API endpoint that allows
github apps to merge their own pull
requests but after discussion we
realized that this is not something we
should enable on our back port bot
system even if the patches applied
cleanly and CI testing passed we still
just think that the careful once-over
required to approve a pull request can't
yet beasts officially replicated by a
bot
now a little bit on to roadmapping I've
talked a bit about how we react to bugs
and short term feature requests but now
I'd like to talk a bit about how we plan
for the not so immediate future for our
team this happens twice a year a
biannual planning summits importantly
these do not just involve the core team
but also members of the community
invested in electrons long term success
and the tooling that exists around it
our last summit was held with about 40
attendees representing a pretty wide
range of products and interests at these
summits we break out into groups to
discuss topics of most interest as
decided at the beginning of the summit
at last summit's end we organized all of
these output items and distill them into
more actionable goals that individuals
our small groups can then assume
responsibility for and drive to the
finish line so how exactly do we
prioritize what it is that we're doing
what we want to do that kind of thing
given the vast amount of things that
we're working on at any given moment how
do we decide what what is the best use
of our time really it's probably most
accurate to say that at a given time we
have a set of individual priorities and
a set of group priorities these
individual priorities might be a small
feature a persnickety bug that's been
bothering one of us for months and a
group priority would be a task towards a
larger overarching group goal like a
blocker for the next beta version recent
changes to our issue reporting have also
made it easier to see what tasks need to
be completed for each version including
current beta cycles we have project
boards organized into columns so that we
can see what blocks versions and
presents big challenges for developers
as well as where those issues are in
pipeline from unassigned all the way to
fix in a certain beta version this is
allowed us to more efficiently divide
and conquer so that users can see their
issues fixed more predictably and
contract the progress of those now where
do we want to go I've talked a lot about
where we are now and where we've been
but where do we want to go in the next
year the year after that a present we've
grouped the output items from our last
summit into four big buckets governance
transparency the release process and
security will start with governance
which I mentioned briefly and I'm not
going to dive a little more deeply into
as we've grown over the past year we've
started to recognize the need for a more
clearly delineated governance system
than we've had for the past several
years that's not to say that what we've
had has proven itself to be insufficient
rather we want to set ourselves up for
the greatest level of success as we see
ourselves on a growth trajectory where
it may one day be insufficient we
believe this change will also allow for
newer developers to start contributing
to the community and understanding its
processes in a way as well as the ways
in which these newer developers can make
their opinions heard and know whom to
talk to
about a given topic or initiative in
terms of transparency we're an
open-source project which by nature
means that all of our source code is
public and its history viewable and
searchable however that's not the end of
the story we have project boards that
aren't always viewable or discoverable
as well as meetings and meeting notes
that are accessible but which developers
may find might not be easily accessible
or wouldn't know where to go to find
them or that sort of thing
to address these gaps we're working to
decide how to make our activities more
available it's also difficult to know
what provides the most value to the
community so to gain better
understanding of that we're currently
soliciting feedback from our ecosystem
and its members in the near future
you'll be able to see a more complete
picture of our progress as well as what
our short and long term goals are in
terms of the release process we've made
some pretty significant updates to that
in the past year as well we switched to
semantic versioning starting with 2.0
and started organizing releases around
major version
I'm sorry around major version upgrades
that they would correspond to chromium
version upgrades this made for a faster
release cadence but we still feel as
though we have a lot to iterate on and
approve we introduced beta versions
recently and in the near future you'll
be able to expect a more predictable
timeline around beta and stable release
versions we're also moving to release
nightly builds which we think help
developers feel more confident in
upgrading as they'll have these builds
to give immediate feedback for how
changes in electron may have broken or
may have broken them and more
incremental and digestible ways
finally security security is something
that's broached a lot by core developers
and users of the framework and is
something we're aware of and working to
improve proactively rather than
reactively as a result we're moving
towards a more secure by default model
which will entail changes to the webview
tag URL handling navigation web contents
and permission handling we'd also like
to improve our story around sandboxing
which we've had for a while but which
could always stand to be improved and
which would help developers feel more
confident in the security status of
their apps as we continue to grow and
improve as a team we'd love to help if
you have questions or interested in
contributing or giving us feedback so
please feel free to reach out thank you
very much
you